quand il y a la pleine lune généralement
les fous sont de sortie des bandes qui
se bagarrent sur fond d'alcool
des entraînements plus que musclés
[Musique]
de jour comme de nuit il veille sur la
population ce sont les anges gardiens du
Nord ces policiers vous invitent à
partager sans fard la réalité de leur
quotidien
[Musique]
en général de l'héroïne leur combat
contre la délinquance sur fond de
violence ordinaire et de misère sociale
donc là on fait prendre du cuivre
bienvenue dans les coulisses du
commissariat central de Lille lundi plus
actifs de France
[Musique]
nous sommes au sud de Lille cet austère
bâtiment en béton surmonté d'une antenne
abrite le centre névralgique du
commissariat
la police secours bonjour oui bonjour je
vous appelle parce que je viens d'avoir
un accident à la sortie oui bonjour
monsieur je vous appelle Pascal des
cambriolages je crois qu'il y a une
agression quelque chose comme ça s'il
vous plaît nous sommes aussi le centre
d'information et de commandement un
service ultra moderne divisé en deux
salles dans la première on réceptionne
les appels du 17 pour tout le
département Nord-Pas-de-Calais
une dizaine de policiers se relaient 24
heures sur 24 à l'écoute des 2200 appels
quotidiens
le 17 positions bonjour Le 17 est
normalement réservé exclusivement aux
urgences mais en réalité les gens
appellent pour tout et n'importe quoi
en fait je note où il y a le parking qui
a le Trésor public
Fouad qui travaille ici depuis deux ans
en sait quelque chose regardez sur
l'annuaire madame vous c'est le 17
polices secours on traite les urgences
c'est vraiment le voilà donc on n'est
pas une plateforme de renseignement au
revoir madame difficile de faire
admettre à certains interlocuteurs
qu'ils engorge inutilement le 17
seulement 12% des appels reçus ici
nécessitent une vraie urgence de police
comme par exemple cet appel d'un
directeur de banque qui craint à hold-up
qui est passionné devant notre
distributeur il savait plus de 10
minutes qui sont en face donc on sait
pas trop quels sont leurs
leurs impôts c'est quoi comme véhicule
une Logan Dacia
break et ils sont garé sur la zone de
livraison
et les villes derrière sont teintées
donc dans le doute je vous appelle quoi
une véritable urgence qu'il s'empresse
de signaler à l'opérateur radio dans
l'autre pièce
ils sont dans une Logan
c'est depuis cette salle de commandement
que les opérateurs passent les appels
radio aux équipes de police secours sur
le terrain cette affaire est prise au
sérieux
[Musique]
depuis plus de 10 minutes sur le
l'emplacement
convoyeur de fonds
radios localisé dont on peut suivre tous
les déplacements sur cette carte à son
bord la brigade de jour ps11 Alfa qui
reçoit l'info 5 sur 5 ce serait bizarre
on aurait quatre individus à bord avec
des bonnets
donc si vous pouvez vous rapprocher pour
ce véhicule et ses individus suspects
ouais c'est bien reçu pour Alpha
j'imagine nous envoyer un autre véhicule
également
et c'est parti l'équipe de Robert fonce
aussitôt vers le lieu de sa mission des
interventions de police secours il y en
a environ 500 par jour à Lille
[Musique]
arrivé sur place les policiers encerclé
le véhicule suspect
le conducteur mais il s'aperçoit
rapidement qu'il s'agit d'une fausse
alerte mais pourquoi vous attendez ici
et voilà cette voiture garée au mauvais
endroit pour une simple pause café à
mobiliser toute une escouade de
policiers
mais pas le temps de se lamenter sur ce
pétard mouillé l'équipe enchaîne
directement sur une histoire plus
sérieuse de faux billets le gérant d'un
supermarché vient d'appeler bonjour
apparemment la copine n'est pas terrible
et les policiers n'ont aucun mal à
distinguer le vrai du faux billet de
banque
vous avez d'autres billets
l'homme n'a sur lui qu'un seul faux
billet de 100 euros mais cela suffit
pour éveiller les soupçons des policiers
[Musique]
ça fait combien de temps que vous êtes
en France Monsieur
[Musique]
dedans pour Robert ces signes sont
suspects
les policiers décident donc de le
ramener au commissariat pour poursuivre
leur interrogatoire
mais la communication est difficile car
l'homme est italien et il parle très mal
le français
what is the name of
[Musique]
l'homme ne parle pas plus anglais ou
allemand
heureusement les policiers peuvent
appeler à la rescousse un de leurs
collègues qui lui par l'italien
mais il n'obtiendra pas grand chose de
plus
tu habites où
on est allé je suis venu ici pour
chercher du travail
c'est quoi ton numéro mon numéro en
France
je me rappelle plus
le suspect n'est pas franchement bavard
mais il parviennent au moins à lui faire
remplir sa fiche d'interpellation il
sera finalement placé en garde à vue
pour la brigade ps11 Alfa la journée
maintenant terminée
[Musique]
21h c'est l'heure de la prise de poste
pour la vacation de nuit à police
secours
jérémy a 30 ans ce soir il est de
service il rejoint les autres équipages
réunis autour du major pour la pelle
bonsoir à tous donc chef de poste alors
BP consulat et Rémi si tu peux faire des
passages cette nuit pour une garde de
garde dynamique en carte de Jérémy c'est
Xavier son coéquipier cela fait 11 ans
qu'il travaille dans les brigades de
nuit
[Musique]
cette PS c'est à dire cette équipe de
police secours qui vont quadriller la
ville jusqu'à 5h du matin
bonne soirée à tous et bon courage
la mission de police secours c'est
d'assurer la sécurité des biens et des
personnes de protéger les habitants
les secteurs sont attribués Xavier
Jeremy peuvent commencer leur patrouille
nocturne
c'est la pleine lune pour avoir du
boulot bah c'est véridique quand il y a
la pleine lune généralement les fous
sont de sortie
[Musique]
Delta à bord du car immatriculée
de fonctionnaires horaire théorique 21h
5h10 pour info on a deux journalistes à
bord et on démuni d'un éthylotest reçu
la première mission du soir vient juste
de tomber direction un grand magasin en
plein centre-ville
deux mineurs de 17 ans aurait volé 4
bouteilles d'alcool de luxe pour une
valeur de 200 euros
bien que très jeune le garçon est déjà
connaisseur il est désormais seul car
son complice présumé prétextant une
envie pressante et parvenue à s'enfuir
craignant qu'il ne se sauve à son tour
Jérémy préfère prendre ses précautions
le jeune homme n'avait pas prévu ça mais
il passera la nuit au commissariat
ce jeune garçon n'en est pas à son coup
d'essai
à 17 ans il est déjà bien connu des
services de police le jeune homme prête
en cas présent il a trouvé du travail
pour gagner de l'argent honnêtement
parce que j'ai arrêté les conneries ça
fait je préfère
il a voulu cependant avoir été dealer à
ses heures ce qui lui rapportait
beaucoup plus que son job sur les
marchés au moins 1000 euros par jour
tout ce qui rapporte
qu'il aimerait bien changer de vie
dans les villes de la rue on va dire je
suis en train de mon pied dans le monde
à pied dans le bien
ça dépend des jours quoi
pour essayer de s'en sortir le garçon
avait intégré une école de coiffure l'an
dernier poursuivi par ses démons il a
abandonné après avoir été placé en
centre d'éducation renforcée suite à une
accumulation de délits le centre
d'éducation renforcé c'est la dernière
alternative avant la prison pour les
mineurs
encore encore
de la procédure d'interpellation les
policiers découvrent que le garçon est
déjà convoqué au tribunal
c'est le service départemental de nuit
qui prend la décision de mettre ou non
les interpeller en garde à vue Jérémy
vient faire son rapport au brigadier de
permanence
le brigadier vient de confirmer la garde
à vue du jeune homme
[Musique]
le jeune est à présent sous la
responsabilité du SDN après sa nuit au
poste il sera remis à ses parents en
attendant sa convocation devant le juge
comme après chaque interpellation Jérémy
doit encore taper le procès-verbal cette
paperasse quotidienne n'entame pas sa
passion pour son métier quand il est
entré dans la police en 2001 il était
l'un des plus jeunes flics de France
j'ai passé le concours à 17 ans en fait
on peut passer le concours à partir de
17 ans et le jour de mes 17 ans j'étais
au commissariat de Béthune chercher un
dossier d'inscription pourtant j'ai pas
de j'ai pas de famille dans la police
mais ça en fait j'avais mon meilleur ami
son père était fonctionnaire de police
et puis il m'a refilé un peu la fibre
quand il nous racontait à son fils et à
moi c'est ses interventions passées et
puis ça a donné ça donnait l'envie de
faire ce beau métier
et l'Office aussi le fils il a essayé il
a pas réussi il est chauffé en route
chez le matin
il est encore tôt les deux coéquipiers
repartent pour une première
reconnaissance des deux rues les plus
chaudes du centre-ville histoire d'en
mesurer l'ambiance
c'est ici que les étudiants viennent se
retrouver pour faire la fête
nous voici les rues de la soif c'est la
concentration de tous les bas vous avez
ma scène sur votre gauche et Solférino
c'est la grande ligne droite donc c'est
quasiment
bar sur bar
[Musique]
mais bon ça peut vite changer
de minuit car avant de sortir en boîte
ou dans les bars les jeunes commencent
presque toujours leur soirée par une
petite fête chez eux et la plupart du
temps ils font trop de bruit résultat
les voisins appellent le 17 pour se
plaindre du tapage nocturne
[Musique]
le locataire des lieux peut sortir avec
une pièce d'identité s'il vous plaît
merci
numéro de téléphone
ils viennent plus forcément vous voir
vous savez moi
on est on est on fait rien du tout
vous baissez le bruit on en reste là
c'est un avertissement
verballée
en tout cas qu'on soit pas rappelé
Albert
pour le moment Xavier et Jérémy font
preuve d'une certaine indulgence
bon là je pense que ils ont compris
puisqu'ils ont pas compris et on est si
on est rappelé bon on les verbalisera
pour un tapage nocturne les gens croient
qu'à partir de 22h on doit plus faire de
bruit mais c'est pas vrai en fait il y a
pas il y a pas d'heure légale pour faire
ou ne pas faire du bruit ce qu'il y a le
souci c'est que les gens de plus aller
voir les voisins pour dire de à mon avis
il y a déjà eu des cas où bah le voisin
qui venait gentiment demander de baisser
la musique alors partez de là avec un
coup de poing ou un coup de pied et puis
ça partait sur des violences donc
maintenant je pense que les gens
ne prennent plus de risques et puis
préfère nous appeler pour que pour qu'on
intervienne quoi
[Musique]
cela fait un peu plus de 4 ans que
Jérémie a intégré les brigades de nuit à
police secours les policiers qui
travaillent la nuit ne touchent qu'une
centaine d'euros de plus par mois par
rapport au service de jour mais ce n'est
visiblement pas l'argent qui les motive
[Musique]
au niveau des horaires quand on a quand
on a des enfants à s'occuper c'est
appréciable on a toutes nos après-midi
après au niveau du boulot c'est vraiment
un monde à part comme c'est pas une
légende quoi le monde de la nuit c'est
vraiment c'est vraiment autre chose et
la nuit on est toujours en intervient
toujours en zone rouge c'est à dire
qu'on se méfie et plus on se méfie plus
qu'en journée à cause du dangereux sur
le coup quand vous avez une intervention
assez palpitante qui a l'adrénaline qui
qui rentre en compte et je pense que en
fait on se rend compte une fois
l'intervention terminée
l'adrénaline il la trouve souvent en fin
de nuit dans ce qu'on appelle les rues
de la soif les jeunes sont alors très
alcoolisés et prêt à se bagarrer pour un
oui ou pour un non
[Musique]
4h du matin un jeune homme vient se
plaindre aux policiers on lui cherche
des noises depuis le début de la soirée
il a frappé en boîte forcément
là je peux pas l'empêcher de
après si vous avez après si vous dérange
on va changer de barre
tu me dérange partout et ce qui me
dérange c'est que partout
vous aviez Jérémy décide d'intervenir
histoire de calmer le jeu et d'éviter
que ça ne tourne en bagarre il y a un
problème
je vous parle comme des frères il y a
pas de problème c'est il y a une
histoire j'ai essayé de parler un peu il
y a tout le monde il pense
la bande féminine d'être réconciliée
mais à peine les policiers ont-ils
tourné le dos
commence à se battre
les policiers décident alors
d'intervenir à nouveau
bon vous allez jouer longtemps comme ça
ou quoi hein
par prudence Jérémie garde sa bombe de
gaz lacrymogène à la main
faut partir il faut pas rester là
si on veut on peut jouer 20 minutes une
demi-heure avec eux en fait c'est le jeu
du chat et la souris quoi ils vont
essayer de nous éviter pour se battre
ailleurs et puis bah quand tu nous vois
arriver tout va bien
tout se folklore fait partie de la vie
nocturne lilloise la présence policière
refroidit les esprits elle est
dissuasive et elle rassure aussi les
gens qui viennent vraiment ici pour
s'amuser
c'est l'heure du retour au commissariat
juste avant de rentrer dernier arrêt
devant cette rôtisserie ambulante
ouverte au petit matin mais ce n'est pas
pour acheter un poulet grillé bonjour ça
va bien ça va et vous avez la PUB
pour votre commerce
salut et pourquoi donc faire de la pub
pour ce monsieur
c'est la famille
rien de tel qu'une bonne petite blague
pour clore une longue nuit de travail
[Musique]
8h du matin une nouvelle journée
commence au commissariat central de
Lille
dans la salle de sport mise à la
disposition des policiers Christophe
vient s'entraîner dès qu'il en a
l'occasion
[Musique]
depuis 7 ans il est formateur en
technique d'intervention pour lui
maintenir une forme physique parfaite
est indispensable
c'est important surtout par rapport à
l'image qu'on donne quelqu'un retenu qui
a une belle allure on a plus envie
d'aller vers lui et puis ça aussi je
pense un peu de respect
oui Christophe a de beaux muscles mais
si l'inspire le respect à ses collègues
c'est surtout pour ses compétences il a
passé 14 ans au GIPN le groupe
d'intervention de la police nationale
mais en fait on interview on intervenait
sur le forcenets
sur les assistances type 6 heures du
matin c'est à dire aller chercher les
dealers de drogue des violeurs etc etc
et ensuite on était habilités à faire
aussi les mutineries dans les prisons
et les protections de personnalité
Christophe est maintenant attendu par
une dizaine de policiers au stand de tir
attention ici les conditions de sécurité
sont très strictes
physiques se font entre le temps
et ici la boîte de minuit
ce matin il supervise une séance
d'entraînement avec Tony un autre
formateur je suis ici je règle mon
marteau en abattu d'accord ça marche je
me relève je repose la main le genou
ok est-ce que c'est clair pour tout le
monde
ce n'est pas une banale séance de tir
les deux moniteurs ont préparé toute une
mise en scène pour que les policiers se
retrouvent au plus près des réalités du
terrain et avant de commencer à tirer
mise en situation obligatoire
c'est parti
ce jeune policier Geoffroy commence par
un programme de 10 pompes et 20 flexions
puis il doit courir en portant un abri
en bois assez lourd
on fait des petits parcours de stress
des petits parcours d'endurance pour
justement faire monter et pulsations
mettre dans un état un petit peu qui se
rapproche d'un état de stress allez
c'est parti
du coup au moment de tirer Geoffroy est
aussi essoufflé que s'il poursuivait
réellement un malfaiteur dans la rue
sécurité Geoffroy se montre un très bon
tireur il doit juste corriger un petit
défaut une sorte
il y a peut-être une seconde ça doit
faire papa d'accord une deux à chaque
fois ok c'est bien
dans ton tir là ici de réaction est-ce
qu'il y a des moments où tu fermes œil
ça m'arrive des fois il faudrait c'est
aussi pour ça que c'est un peu parasite
si tu prends du temps pour faire mais un
œil ton double top ça va faire boum boum
alors que si tu prends pas ce temps pour
fermer un œil et tu sois plus concentré
sur ta sur ton action de tir à ce
moment-là tu vas être beaucoup plus
rapide
les policiers doivent faire au moins
trois séances comme celle-ci chaque
année c'est obligatoire l'arme qu'ils
utilisent c'est le six sauver qui tient
des balles de 9 mm
donc le policier lorsqu'il arrive dans
la police à son arme individuelle il
regarde toute sa carrière ce numéroté il
y a un numéro de série ça évite déjà les
échanges les pertes en plus le
fonctionnaire responsable de son arme et
de son entretien forcément voilà
pourquoi ici vous avez après la séance
de tir tous les tous les collègues qui
nettoient leurs armes de plus toutes les
armes sont révisées chaque année par les
armuriers
merci au plaisir
[Musique]
loin du centre historique de Lille
de l'autre côté de la ville se trouve
les quartiers récemment classés zone de
sécurité prioritaire des quartiers qui
concentre bien des mots recrutement de
bandes vol de voiture circulation
d'armes et surtout trafic de drogue
cette petite antenne de police dépend
elle aussi du commissariat central situé
en plein cœur de la zone sensible à
Lille Sud elle abrite la BST la brigade
spécialisée de terrain
cela fait 20 ans qu'olivien fait partie
et qu'il patrouille dans ses rues pour
traquer toute forme de délinquance
pour débuter la journée visite dans le
gigantesque camp de Rome illicite
implanté en pleine ville sur un terrain
privé
un bidonville de trois hectares où
habite 600 personnes venues de Roumanie
de Slovaquie et de Bulgarie
l'un des problèmes récurrents dans cette
cour des miracles c'est que pour
survivre certains ici voleraient des
câbles en cuivre on va s'assurer qu'il y
a pas du câble qui proviendrait de
l'essai enfin de la SNCF on a beaucoup
beaucoup de vols de métaux des feux
petit fond fondre le cuivre je sais plus
combien elle est le
kilo
ils font ça et puis après ils refourguer
ça des ferrailleurs plus scrupuleux
qu'est-ce que tu fais cramer là
c'est toi qui fait cramer des trucs
Olivier vient de repérer un feu bien à
l'abri des regards sous ce hangar
ça va comme vous voulez là
donc là on fait fondre du cuivre pour
revendre le câble volé ils doivent
d'abord brûler la gaine en plastique qui
l'entoure et ce feu dégage des gaz
toxiques
parfois ces méthodes déclenchent des
incendies extrêmement graves
les policiers viennent de surprendre ces
hommes en flagrant délit mais problème
comme c'est ce sera pas possible de
savoir d'où ça vient
on peut pas faire tenir du recel sur
trois bouts de cuivre malheureusement
les quantités de métal brûlées
aujourd'hui sont insuffisantes et faute
de preuves sur leur provenance les
policiers doivent en rester là après
avoir fait éteindre le feu
mais ils ne font pas chou blanc à chaque
fois
un peu plus tard que la semaine dernière
là on a ramassé à peu près combien de
kilos
centaines de kilos à peu près
le cuivre volé ce n'est pas ce qui
mobilise le plus la St
l'essentiel de sa mission c'est la lutte
contre le trafic de drogue
principalement de l'héroïne et du
cannabis une économie parallèle
florissante qui se développe ouvertement
même en plein jour au pied de ces
immeubles
donc en fait là c'est un endroit où les
toxicomanes viennent consommer à l'abri
des regards on voit des pochons là
petits pochons vides
qui referme en général de l'héroïne
on en trouve tout le long du bâtiment là
le trafic de drogue et le fléau des
quartiers
et le moment idéal pour déloger les
toxicos et les dealers du coin c'est
surtout quand la nuit est tombée
le soir ça prend plus belle puisque
forcément c'est plus facile à dissimuler
le soir que la journée donc le trafic
est beaucoup plus important le soir
Olivier connaît son secteur comme sa
poche il sait où aller chercher
[Musique]
les deux policiers viennent de repérer
quelques jeunes dans le hall de cet
immeuble il les prennent en chasse
impossible d'être discret car
contrairement à la BAC qui travaille en
civil la BST est en tenue alors quand
elle arrive quelque part elle est tout
de suite repérée par les bandes
en fait il y a trois quatre jeunes qui
étaient dans le hall le problème c'est
qu'ils nous ont vu il y en a qui s'est
barré
ça c'est un petit pochon pour le pour le
cannabis
aujourd'hui cela devient un exploit
d'arrêter les trafiquants car ils sont
de plus en plus malins
et ce n'est pas tout les dealers
narguent la police grâce à des
techniques de surveillance très au point
par exemple à cet étage ou pour notre
sécurité on nous demande de tourner en
caméra cachée les guetteurs ont cassé
cette fenêtre pour se créer un poste
d'observation idéal donc en fait dès
qu'on arrive avant de l'immeuble ça crie
d'en face
ils ont un étage à monter jusqu'à chez
un appart le problème c'est que pour les
gens qui habitent ici insupportable de
rentrer chez soi et de d'enjamber des
jeunes qui sont en train de Diler on va
voir des crachats comme il y en a
partout
[Musique]
le rôle de la BST c'est un peu de
traquer l'intraquable même si le père
souvent la partie contre les trafiquants
Olivier ne se décourage pas ça fait 20
ans que je fais ça donc le jour j'en ai
marre je me mettrai dans un bureau
pour l'instant ça me plaît
la BST est une brigade de proximité qui
n'hésite pas à aller partout pour
assainir les zones de non-droit et
maintenir la paix dans les quartiers
une autre unité spécialisée est amenée à
arrêter les trafiquants chez eux
ces hommes doivent garder l'anonymat
quand ils sont en mission ils sont
toujours cagoulés ce sont des policiers
chevronnés rattachés à la brigade de
sûreté départementale la BSD
il travaille sur des enquêtes au long
cours qui se terminent parfois par des
interpellations musclées sur le terrain
aujourd'hui on travaille beaucoup sur
les home jacking les équipes de Home
Jacky
de stupe aujourd'hui
majorité des gens ont la possibilité
d'avoir une arme chez eux donc
on préfère pallier à toute situation
avec les mots aujourd'hui ils suivent
une formation avec Christophe la brigade
compte sur l'expérience de cet ancien du
GIPN pour perfectionner les techniques
d'intervention ok bonjour monsieur
bonjour à tous donc aujourd'hui on va
faire un stage bouclier balistique
souple
avec les progressions en milieu confinés
donc vous allez évoluer essentiellement
dans des appartements donc on va aller
chercher à chaque fois des gens dans des
appartements ok
l'équipement est ultra lourd il y a les
matraques ce bélier a vérin qui peut
exercer jusqu'à 7 tonnes de pression
pour enfoncer les portes sans compter le
casque avec visière par balle de 3 cm
d'épaisseur qui pèse à lui seul plus de
3 kg
s'il vous plaît et en plus les hommes
portent les bébés s ces boucliers
pliable qui protègent efficacement des
balles mais qui sont encombrants au
cours d'un assaut ils doivent apprendre
à se déplacer avec et c'est quand vous
voulez
attention c'est comme au cinéma l'action
se passe dans cet immeuble désaffecté
l'idée c'est de déloger un truand reclus
chez lui Christophe a prévu plusieurs
scénarios de plus en plus complexes il
joue lui-même un rôle dans ses
mini-fictions se transforment d'abord en
dealer de drogue planqué dans sa salle
de bain
[Musique]
pour finir il devient un forcené russe
qui menace de tirer sur les policiers
parce qu'il ne veut pas finir en prison
ils vont dire m'interpeller et là je
vais résister un petit peu
non viens me chercher
d'abord donc tu rentres dans la pièce
négatif ouvre la porte ouvre-toi même la
porte je recule de la porte tu peux
l'ouvrir
[Musique]
si je la poste tu me promets de rien
faire
tu veux que je la pose
moi je m'allonge pas
[Musique]
franchement on s'y croirait
et voilà opération terminée ennemie
maîtriser
sur le dos
très impressionnant même si on sait que
tout ça c'était pour de faux
côté police secours Xavier et Jérémy
entame leur deuxième nuit consécutive
[Musique]
pas le temps de dire ouf c'est déjà
parti Xavier traverse la ville pied au
plancher
[Musique]
un véhicule le véhicule apparemment il
s'est il s'est planté à l'entrée de
l'autoroute donc on va aller on va aller
sécuriser l'entrée de l'autoroute
c'est une BMW qui a été repérée et
poursuivi un peu plus tôt par la brigade
anti-criminalité la BAC
à son bord il y avait quatre jeunes
leurs courses poursuite c'est
brutalement terminé
ils ont percutés ils ont essayé de
s'enfuir ils veulent jouer avec nous
mais des fois ils perdent comme ils ont
perdu
la petite bande a déjà eu des démêlés
avec la police
leur voiture n'est pas un véhicule volé
en revanche le chauffeur n'a pas le
permis de conduire il est donc embarqué
par la BAC pour passer la nuit en garde
à vue
le défaut de permis est un délit il
risque jusqu'à 2 ans de prison et une
interdiction de passer le permis
je rentre chez moi je vous [__] les
trois autres occupants eux peuvent
rentrer chez eux la police n'a rien à
leur reprocher
quant à la voiture elle est enlevée le
soir même direction la fourrière
pour l'intervention suivante changement
d'univers radical
[Musique]
le campus
apparemment 17 c'était difficilement
comprendre
c'est bien pris
cette fois les policiers sont dirigés
vers l'un des quartiers les plus
défavorisés de l'île
[Musique]
passez la porte d'entrée il règne une
odeur pestile ancienne dans le couloir
de l'immeuble
c'est la locataire de l'appartement qui
a appelé le 17 mais c'est un homme qui
accueille Xavier Jérémy
bonsoir c'est la police
c'est vous qui avez fait appel à nous
non c'est pas moi c'est mon ex concubine
c'était après son nouveau concubin et
les parties sont occupé il est parti
monsieur
une femme son ancien compagnon et son
nouveau conjoint trois personnes qui
auraient passer la soirée ensemble dans
cet appartement à l'état de taudis
Xavier doit même remonter son écharpe
devant son nez pour supporter la
puanteur qui règne ici
et on est chez qui ici on est chez vous
ici vous êtes chez elle je suis SDF
monsieur
[Applaudissements]
les policiers tentent de reconstituer ce
puzzle sur fond de misère sociale
mais il est difficile de comprendre le
récit incohérent de leur interlocuteur
l'urgence est maintenant de vérifier
s'il y a eu des violences ou non
je sais pas écoutez je veux pas être
méchant avec elle mais il y a un mais
toujours mais à chaque coup qu'elle
pense sonner dans l'alcool ça y est elle
commence d'accord
enfin bref
ce soir les policiers n'en apprendront
pas plus
c'est toujours la même histoire toujours
allez à plus tard
on découvre ici une autre facette de
leur métier
un rôle d'assistante sociale qui assume
souvent les équipes de police secours
malheureusement on s'y habitué quoi donc
ça fait partie
ça fait partie du boulot genre
d'intervention c'est vrai que c'est
malheureux pour ces personnes mais bon
on a on va dire qu'on s'attarde pas trop
non plus sur sur leur code parce que
sinon
des gens sur notre dos
2h30 du matin certaines nuits les
équipes ont une halte au commissariat
juste le temps d'un repas préparé par le
chef de poste grâce à une petite
cagnotte à laquelle tout le monde
participe menu du jour des frites
et du cassoulet pas très diététique mais
effet anti froid garanti
c'est une région viticole
le temps nous le permet on se fait un
petit plaisir entre collègues oh c'est
pas toujours le cas bah c'est selon
l'activité on est dépendant de
l'activité qui est dehors une dernière
frite vite avalée car justement de
l'activité ce soir il y en a
Xavier Jérémy sont déjà repartis pour
une dernière ronde dans les rues de la
soif
ils doivent gérer les débordements des
noctambules jusqu'à la fermeture des
boîtes de nuit
des débordements qui peuvent prêter à
sourire sur le chemin du retour Xavier
remarque tout à coup un jeune homme en
train d'uriner sur le mur d'une boutique
ça va
[Musique]
réfléchir et surtout apprendre par cœur
ce petit extrait du code pénal
des emplacements autorisés les
pansements d'urine 26513
le jeune homme vient de prendre malgré
lui une leçon de civisme dont il se
souviendra sans doute long temps des
ivrognes la nuit on ne retrouve partout
même sous les roues des voitures
qu'est-ce qu'on disait sur l'alcool tout
à l'heure
nous quand mais contrairement aux
précédents c'est de là font sourire
Jérémy
des jeunes qui s'amusent ils ont un peu
bu mais ils s'amusent
à notre égard ils sont pas ils sont pas
provocateurs et en tout ça donc bon
ok messieurs cette fois c'est l'heure
d'aller se coucher pour de bons
quand il ne s'absente pas plus de deux
jours du commissariat un policier a le
droit d'emporter son arme de service
chez lui par prudence Xavier préfère
laisser la leur au placard
pour eux la vacation de nuit est
terminée
dans le couloir il croise la relève
leurs collègues qui arrivent déjà pour
la prise de poste du matin
car au commissariat central de Lille on
ne s'arrête jamais c'est une histoire
sans fin
[Musique]